hi last time we talked about nvcc method
and how to reduce the number of
equations we had to deal with to solve a
particular circuit at this point we're
pretty well equipped to solve circuits
in the general sense but we really
haven't talked about how to use that
information or possibly use circuits in
a particular way Before we jump into
both that and abstraction of circuits we
need to talk about op amps op amps is
short for operational amplifier and it's
a tool that we can use in order to
sample particular voltages from a
subsection of the circuit without
affecting it another thing we can use op
amps to do is modify our signal or if
we're going to sample a voltage from a
particular subsection of the circuit we
can then do stuff to that voltage
without affecting the circuit all within
the op amp or within the op amps special
subsets of circuitry so first of all
what is an operational amplifier well
operational amplifier is a giant web of
transistors but nopper a tional what an
operational amplifier does is act as a
voltage dependent voltage source it can
effectively sample voltages from a
existing circuit and then use them to
power some other object for it for
instance a light bulb if you set up this
kind of circuit you will not actually be
powering this light bulb with 5 volts
because the light bulb itself acts as a
resistor and so the voltage drop across
this part of the circuit is going to be
different from just 5 volts if you want
to enable a voltage drop of 5 volts
across this light bulb then you have to
stick up an op-amp you have to use an
op-amp to sample the voltage drop at
this component and put it in between the
light bulb and the rest of the circuit
when you see an op-amp Lona schematic
diagram it will frequently look like
this you'll have a positive input
voltage a negative image power rails
which were actually the thing that
determined the range of expressivity
that the ALP amp has and an output
voltage in reality the relationship
between the output voltage and the input
voltages is something like this
where K is a very large number the
effect that this has is that V out is
going to be whatever V out needs to be
such that V Plus is equal to V minus
that's the basic rule you want to use
when you're interacting with op amps so
in this case if we wanted to power this
light bulb with five volts we would do
something like this
excuse the sloppiness of the second
diagram we still have our 10 volt
voltage source we still have our voltage
divider this point samples 5 volts from
this sub circuit and isolates this part
of the circuit from the light bulb V out
has to be whatever value is necessary
such that this sample point and this
sample point are equal since this value
is 5 volts this value will also be
driven to 5 volts by the op-amp which
means that this value is 5 volts and
we've successfully managed to power our
light bulb with 5 volts the other thing
you might be asked to do is to take an
existing schematic an existing a circuit
diagram and figure out what the
operational amplifier does to a given
signal or possibly what V out is or
possibly what V out is in terms of the
input signal so let's practice using
this diagram
here's what we're after I can figure out
what v+ is going to be this is another
voltage divider
I'm now interested in V - in terms of V
out which is another voltage divider
I can set these two equations equal to
one another and solve for V up
I found an expression for V out in the
particular case where V is 10 volts
if my input voltage we were previously
unspecified or if this voltage source
pardon
we're not specified or just be in then I
would be after this expression some
things I'd like to mention while we're
talking about op amps all the
operational amplifiers we've been
working with so far deal with V out in
terms of VN where VN is driven through
the positive terminal and the negative
terminal is typically connected to
ground you can do the opposite and end
up with some interesting effects but it
comes at a cost it is entirely possible
that you will end up driving your op-amp
to an unstable equilibrium what you need
to look at is this relationship
there may be a particular point in which
case your system is stable but if you
get any sort of minor perturbations
you'll actually end up with divergence
if this is the case then you'll probably
burn out your album you can do this by
hooking it up in this way
this is expensive and could possibly
burn you the other thing to note is that
the power rails on your op-amp limit its
range of expensive 'ti and I think I've
said this before but it's worth
mentioning again if your op-amp is only
powered by 10 volts it cannot amplify
your input signal to a final value
greater than 10 volts
likewise if your input value is a
negative voltage and you're working with
a non-inverting amplifier if your ground
is truly ground or if your ground is
higher relative than your input voltage
you cannot actually express a negative
voltage the third thing I'd like to
quickly mention is that there are some
terms associated with op amps that you
might hear used by the staff or online
that sort of thing
a buffer and a voltage follower are the
same thing and that's explicitly when
you want to sample a signal or you want
to sample a particular voltage and you
don't want to multiply it or add it to
something or do you know any of any kind
of LTI operations that we might be able
to do using op amps in this course you
can work with amplifiers and the thing
we worked with earlier was an amplifier
for value less than 1 you can also use
op amps to some signals and if you look
for a voltage summer amplifier on the
internet you should be able to find some
information in any case op amps are
really powerful they allow us to both
isolate a particular section of a
circuit and sample a particular voltage
value from that circuit without
affecting that circuit and also allow us
to modify that particular voltage value
before using it in another part of our
overall circuit therefore were enabled
to design more complicated and powerful
things next time I'll talk about LTI
I'll talk about superposition and
Thevenin and Norton equivalents which
will further enable modularity and
abstraction in our circuit design